the battle of heaven and earth is the
most important battle in the entire
attack on titan this battle is between
the combined forces of warriors and
survey corps against aaron and his army
of colossal titans
as the flying boat travels towards fort
solta armin notes that due to obtaining
the warhammer titan aaron may not be
residing within the nape of the founding
titan and discusses with both the
warriors and corps members about various
means to incapacitate the founding titan
the meeting is interrupted as the group
is being pulled into paths by aaron as
his comrades tried to talk aaron down
mikasa pleads for aaron to return to
them seeing aaron in the distance armin
mikasa and the others strive to reach
him but are unable to get any closer
aaron tells them that he has no
intention of stopping he proclaims that
he will take all of the world's freedom
so he can achieve his own but he
promises not to deny the alliance's
freedom to thwart his plans however
aaron reinforces his intent to destroy
the world refusing to negotiate on any
terms and stating that the only thing to
stop his advance would be his death
before sending them back to the flying
boat the emotional survey corps realizes
that they have no other option but to
fight aaron they armed themselves with
vertical maneuvering equipment and
explosives to detonate at the base of
the founding titan's head
while leaving on the azumabito boat
falco and gabby plead with annie to let
them help with the efforts to stop the
rumbling due to ingesting zeke's spinal
fluid falco recalls memories of a former
beast titan that was capable of flight
and is confident he can do the same
after kyomi yelena and the crew
abandoned ship falco does indeed
generate an avian form of the jaw titan
and flies in the direction of the
aaron's founding titan with both annie
and gabby riding atop his back as both
groups head towards a rendezvous the
marlian military has received numerous
reports of the wall titans quickly
overrunning the continent as survivors
and refugees begin to reach fort salta
war secretary mueller orders soldiers to
drop explosives on the quickly
approaching titans unfortunately the
founding titan summons zeke's beast
titan form and shoots down the airships
with projectiles and eliminates all of
them rendering the fort defenseless
as the flying boat approaches aaron it
is struck by several projectiles and one
of the wings is destroyed armin orders
the beast titan to be a top priority
target and as anjan capone maneuvers the
damaged ship directly over the founding
titan both soldiers and warriors jump
out of the ship as the final battle for
humanity begins the group notices that
zeke's beast titan dissolved soon after
reiner went to attack it alerting them
that zeke was not inside it as the
others retreat so armin can transform
into the colossus titan he is captured
by another titan resembling an okapi
many more titans begin to spawn atop the
founding titans back reacting with
hostility and driving the soldiers back
peak realizes that the titans they are
facing are resurrected versions of the
nine titans from over the last two
thousand years realizing that aaron can
generate an infinite number of titans
pique tries to rush to his nape on her
own and use the explosives to kill him
she manages to set the explosives around
his nape but before she can set them off
her titan gets impaled by laura tiber's
warhammer titan before the group can
make any progress bertholdt's colossus
titan appears and grabs reiner it
attempts to devour him but reiner is
rescued from his titan's nape by gene at
the last second the colossus titan
throws reiner's titan at the group and
the impact knocks them all the way from
aaron's titan reiner and jean's
maneuvering equipment are busted and
they are left stranded hanging 400
meters above the ground reiner tries to
convince gene to let him go so he can
transform again but gene points out that
he will only be crushed by the colossus
titans beneath aaron as the nine titans
of the past begin to attack the group is
rescued by the arrival of falco who has
learned to fly with his jaw titan
as they approach fort salta the soldiers
tried to come up with their next move
gabby reveals that when aaron's founding
titans spawned in shigashina a large
centipede creature erupted from his body
that reconnected his neck and believes
that it could happen if the head and
neck are separated once again leva
decides to stay aboard the jaw titan due
to his injuries and provide support with
gabby while the others returned to the
founding titan and split into two teams
mikasa connie and annie will track down
the titan that took arm in while eugene
and reiner travel towards the head and
nape where the explosives are everyone
agrees and falco flies towards aaron he
avoids a barrage of arrows shot at them
from the various warhammer titans and
after depositing both teams continues
circling around the founding titans so
gabby can disable the titans with her
rifle
reiner gets overrun by the numerous
warhammer titans and is repeatedly shot
and stabbed with arrows and pikes
generated by them having been pinned
down near the nape of the founding titan
pique emerges from the kart titan and
begins to transform and tear apart
numerous titans nearby repeatedly
meanwhile the other team spots the okapi
titan that kidnapped armin and mikasa
signals annie to throw her towards it
despite this more titans spawn in corner
mikasa while keeping her and the others
away from the okapi titan inside the
titan's mouth armin begins to suffocate
he concludes that emir is the one
generating titans to defend aaron and
begins to lament that he and his
comrades are powerless to stop the two
of them as he begins to pass out armand
sees berthold hoover standing before him
crying armin stares down at his
unconscious body and grows frustrated
that it will not move thinking that he
is dead as he remembers his friends he
begins insulting himself lamenting that
all he ever does is let himself and
others down as he angrily proclaims that
he has wasted the second chance at life
he was given armin realizes that he is
surrounded by sand seeing the sand armin
realizes that the fact that he can still
see and think means that he is still
alive realizing he is in the paths again
armin thinks that he might be able to
continue helping his friends through the
connections all eldians have in paths
however his thinking is almost
immediately derailed when he sees zeke
jaeger sitting nearby he introduces
himself to zeke and zeke asks armin if
amir has consumed him armin sits with
zeke and listens as zeke explains his
theory about the origin of life zeke
theorizes that all life forms find their
meaning by multiplying and that it was a
resultant fear of death that caused emir
to spawn her undying titan body and
escape to the world of the paths zeke
theorizes that the reason she continued
to obey the fritz family for two
thousand years was because she still
felt a connection to the world and that
she likely chose to help aaron because
he was the first person able to
understand her ermins tries to get zeke
to tell him how to escape the pathworld
but zeke believes there is no point in
continuing to fight seeing a leaf stuck
in the soil armin recalls a time in his
youth when he raced aaron and mikasa to
the top of a hill outside shigashina
recounting the memory to zeke armin
claims that at that moment he had felt
that the only reason he had been born
was to try to race his friends he had
felt that same way reading as a child
feeding small animals and shopping with
his friends showing zeke the leaf from
the soil armin claims that even though
he does not need it to live it is still
precious to him he hands zeke the leaf
and is shocked to see the human forms of
many past titan inheritors standing
behind him as zeke wakes up the
inheritors armin notices emir fritz
swatching them from the distance before
turning to see bear thought
acknowledging his role in berthold's
death armin asks his former ally to help
him at the same time zeke thanks grisha
and tom for everything and asks them to
lend him their strength
all of a sudden many of the spawned
titans begin to turn against each other
and provide support for the beleaguered
soldiers berthold saves annie who was
overrun by titans marcel and porco jump
into save jean and peek while amir in
her jaw titan form manages to save
reiner just in time levi notices the
okapi titan and instructs gabby to shoot
it in the head mikasa also rushes
towards the titan and slices apart its
jaws to free armin as the number of
titan shifters fight among each other
zeke emerges from the founding titan and
calls out to levi he remarks about how
life truly is worth living and that he
was stupid not to notice it before levi
flies over and swiftly decapitates him
before returning back to the jaw titan
this causes all of the rumbling to stop
gene rushes towards the founding titan's
head before detonating the explosives
calling him stupid little suicidal
blockhead this blows off the head of the
founding titan and as it falls towards
the ground the centipede creature does
indeed emerge to try and reconnect it
reiner starts to wrestle with the
centipede in an attempt to keep it away
from aaron's head informed that armin
will try to destroy aaron by
transforming into the colossus titan
gene rendezvouses with peak and they'd
retreat to the jaw titan with the others
as falco flies back to fort salta armin
is held in the hands of tom's beast
titan and berthold's colossus titan
thanking their predecessors for helping
them achieve their goal he transforms
and blows apart the rest of the founding
titan's body with a massive explosion
the survey corps and warriors fly back
to fort sultan and as falco lands the
warriors reunite with their loved ones
the survey gore can't believe they were
actually able to achieve the impossible
and stop the rumbling armin's colossus
titan emerges from the crater unharmed
while reiner's armored titan slowly gets
up nearby due to the mass amounts of
steam covering the area they believe
aaron was killed and make their way to
fort salta as well just then a large
flash comes from the crater and aaron
emerges in a titan body similar in
appearance and size to the colossus
titan armin confronts him and begins to
fight his former friend at the same time
reiner notices the source also survived
and it begins to billow a gas that
floats towards the fort the inhabitants
in fort sultan noticed this as well and
connie knows that the gas is similar to
the one expelled in ragako that turned
the village into titans realizing what
is about to happen levi quickly orders
mikasa and peak to get back aboard falco
with him and depart as they watch their
companions to park gene uses that he and
connie are going to have to entrust
their allies to finish the job for them
as they are about to transform connie
jokes that it is gene's fault that they
are burdened with the job of saving the
world since he was the one who convinced
them to join the survey corps
soon after they gabby and all the other
albions are transformed into titans and
quickly rushed toward the centipede to
save it from reiner annie and pique
immediately transformed to help reiner
but all three are quickly overwhelmed by
the swarm of titans ignoring the horde
armin attempts to grapple aaron
declaring that he will fight him until
the very end he is swiftly disadvantaged
when aaron lands a devastating blow
against his own head caving armin's
titan's face in as levi and mikasa come
closer to aaron mikasa experiences
another strong headache and is suddenly
brought into the paths by aaron she
finds herself in the alternate reality
where she is living in isolation with
aaron following their decision to run
away from the paradis marlian conflict
erin notices that mikasa has been crying
and mikasa wonders if it is okay for her
to be there aaron muses that the only
option they had was to run away and live
out the rest of his four years in peace
together since he could not bring
himself to rumble the people living
outside the walls mikasa apologizes for
bringing up the past and aaron asks her
to forget about him when he dies mikasa
wakes up in the real world and says that
she cannot forget him tying her scarf
around her neck once again mikasa tells
levi that aaron is inside his titan's
mouth and asks him to help her reach him
levi fires a thundersphere that blows
apart some of the teeth in the titan's
mouth big enough for mikasa to get
through she sees aaron's head and spine
and is momentarily taken aback when
aaron looks towards her and acknowledges
her presence mikasa recovers and vows to
always remember aaron she then severs
his head and kisses aaron goodbye as
emir looks on once aaron is killed by
mikasa emir fritz is freed and the power
of the titans disappears the surviving
titans also turn back to their human
forms but are quickly confronted by
those of the marlian military both sides
learn that the titans are no more due to
the death of aaron yeager which armin
claims responsibility for three years
after the battle of heaven and earth the
survivors of the battle embark on
paradis as ambassadors for marley to
begin peace negotiations with the island
leaders as they sail for the island they
read a letter from historia which
explains that the remaining jaegerists
have formed an army to defend paradis
from the threat of the outside world
click on this video where we covered 40
small details you didn't know about
aaron yeager trust me it's a must watch